[Music]
could I put MS what might seem a very
radical idea economically speaking that
follows perhaps from what means has just
said one of the most radical things that
any government have left-to-right could
do if it wanted to is to make labor as
free as possible encourage immigration
to be as free as possible rather than
being restricted in some ways that's a
right-wing policy rather than a
left-wing one is it one that you would
welcome as an economic libertarian so I
I believe that we you know we do need
immigration in our country that it is
incredibly important but that there
should be limits so I think we've got
the balance right at the moment we're
moving towards you know allowing more
skilled people in particular to come to
the UK to fill skills gaps but we also
need to make sure that people in this
country are able to have opportunities
and trained up for the job so I don't
think I don't think there is anyone in
the political spectrum who would
advocate a completely free immigration
system and I don't think there is anyone
who would advocate you know simply
closing our borders so I think we're all
talking about you know points on a
points on a continuum but if you talk
about trajectory rather than points in a
continuing the conversation I think
about right at the moment so I think
we're in I think we're moving in the
right direction to a more skills based
system I think that commands popular
sport but I think she was we want to see
numbers lower them no I mean I think the
issue was on to the Blair government
that people weren't engaged in that
conversation that the government went
off did staff didn't really talk about
it I noticed now when I talk to people
in my constituency they're much more
aware of the need for example in
agriculture to make sure we have enough
differences north in Norfolk to do those
roles I think people are aware that you
know we don't have enough doctors in the
NHS and the extra allowance we've made
for visas is a good thing
but I think there was a lack of
political debate about this issue and it
the point I was making earlier which i
think is relevant about economics is
we've moved away from assist
where people voted for political parties
basically based on how much they earn I
think we are now moving to a system
where people are voting on values and
they want to hear what politicians stand
for and if we just sit there and spout
platitudes that anyone can agree with
and aren't honest about what we think I
think that is where people get
disillusioned with politics and that
allows you know organizations like the
far rap right to go into that vacuum for
more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV
you